avec nous donc maintenant le ministre de
l'immigration jean boulet bonsoir
monsieur goulet bonsoir monsieur fini
ans quand on dit fermer le chemin oxame
ça veut dire quoi exactement
ben ça veut dire faire exactement ce qui
a été fait entre le 20 mars de melgven
et le 21 novembre 2021 date de sa
réouverture donc on demande aux
personnes qui veulent soumettre une
demande d'asile et qui sont aux
etats-unis de le faire dans ce pays là
et ça on a fait ça à cause de la
pandémie parce qu'il y avait la coved 19
qui vous avait même dit un certain
moment que la copie de pouvant entrer
par le ch me roxane non c'est pas ça
vous avez dit non ses passagers j'ai par
l amalgame j'ai pas dit que ces
personnes-là fait entrer la cage vide il
fallait respecter la capacité
d'accueillir ces personnes là qu'il
fallait surtout être prudente dans ce
contexte elle met donc la suspension
temporaire durant la pandémie vous
pensez que cette suspension de l'entente
sur les tiers pays sûrs
devrait devrait se poursuivre c'est à
dire que les personnes ne devraient plus
pouvoir passer la frontière et demandé
l'asile au québec au canada tout à fait
on vit un système de deux poids deux
mesures il ya des personnes qui
empruntent les voies régulière fond tout
le processus pour demander l'asile au
canada et au québec alors que d'autres
prennent le chemin roxane sachez
monsieur fignon que 92 % des entrées
régulières au canada se font par le
chemin roxane ce que je demande c'est
que l'entente sur les tiers pays sûrs
soit respectée du moins dans son esprit
à défaut qu'on la mette de côté qu'on
suspende son application et qu'on
s'assure de négociation qui diligente et
qui se fait de manière ferme avec les
états unis pour qu'on se comprenne bien
que ce boulet une personne qui arrive à
la frontière qui arrive à la douane des
états unis et qui va entrer au canada y
demander l'asile il va se faire dire non
automatiquement
donc ce qu'il fait c'est qu'il passe par
un chemin régulier en ce moment ces
chemins rock semble qu'ils aient comme
la canalisation pour être capable
d'entrer au canada et de demander
l'asile non il ya des personnes qui
peuvent emprunter les voies régulière
qui viennent d'autres pays d'ailleurs
ces restes humains voilà la voie
aérienne par exemple qui arrivent à
l'aéroport pierre elliott trudeau il
rencontre les agents frontaliers sauce
est une des voies régulier n'est
actuellement il emprunte rock semble qui
est une voie illégale parce que
l'entente détient pays sur n'est pas
respectée où doit être redéfinie
renégocier de manière à éviter l'emprunt
de cette voie qu'il tire grillage
l'habituel qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ces gens-là de ces personnes-là de ces
dizaines de milliers de personnes on
s'en va on a eu cette nuit là au premier
trimestre il y en a eu plusieurs
dizaines de milliers avant la pandémie
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces gens là
sont des gens dans la souffrance
qu'ils ont qui aimeraient faire autre
chose que de passer une frontière
terrestre comme cette façon irrégulière
non c'est extrêmement important pour moi
de réitérer que le québec est une terre
d'accueil et humanitaire on a une
excellente réputation
le 23 novembre dernier deux jours après
la réouverture
j'ai eu un entretien avec mes homologues
à ottawa il ya de monsieur médicinaux
monsieur duclos monsieur fraize 20 piges
était accompagné de mon collègue
québécois à la santé on a convenu d'une
réouverture ordonné fait en
collaboration dans le respect d'une
capacité d'hébergement de 11 150 et d'un
flux quotidiens de 60 la capacité
d'hébergement est atteinte le flux
quotidien est régulièrement des pensées
et l'oeil en ne trouvant à 80 100 110 et
monsieur fini on lit personnes résidants
du nord 10 par jour c'est par jour il ya
des personnes monsieur fignon là qui
arrivent ici ils sont hébergés
temporairement durée moyenne de 15 jours
75 % d'entre elles demeurent au québec
font des demandes aide financière de
dernier recours relève de la station
combien ce boulet ses 11 150 pour
l'hébergement et le flux quotidien c'est
60 lots sur les 13 mai at st mathieu
filion qui sont arrivés chez nous depuis
le 21 novembre dernier 10800 ont fait
une demande d'être financière de dernier
recours et on n'est pas capables les
accompagner pour
réintégration ou une
réponse à nos besoins concrets des
entreprises en pénurie de main d'oeuvre
parce que le permis de travail n'est pas
émis avant l'écoulement d'une période de
11 mois je comprends bien donc vous
demander à ottawa d'accélérer vous
demandé à ottawa de revoir l'entente sur
les tiers pays sûrs avec avec les états
unis dernier point que je vais aborder
avec vous monsieur le ministre ce soir
le québec va accueillir
si je me trompe pas un nombre record
d'immigrants 2022 70 mail immigrants
permanent parce qu'on veut rattraper la
baisse de 2020 particulièrement et quoi
encore environ trente mille travailleurs
étrangers temporaires
non bon il ya le volet immigration temps
par un puis le volet immigration
permanente les seuls québécois qui
découle la planification pluriannuelle
met le saint québécois au niveau des
admissions à la résidence permanente 50
2500 et sow il faut tenir compte d'un
rééquilibrage le nombre d'admissions qui
n'ont pas été faites en 2020 qui font
partie d'un d'un ricky les branches qui
doit se faire par ottawa donc ses 52
mais l'admission donc dans le respect
des seuils d'immigration établi par
québec mais il ya un rattrapage à faire
pour les émissions qui n'ont pas été
faits en 2020 notre seuil était alors à
44 milles ottawa n'en a admis que 26000
en raison de la fermeture des frontières
donc année record pour l'immigration en
2022 au québec monsieur ministre un nom
c'est une année qui
respectueuse de nos seuils d'immigration
établi sur les trois ans souhaite à la
planification pluriannuelle qui était
consécutive à des consultations et pour
l'immigration tant par un bella on a
obtenu des assouplissements souhaitent à
des dialogues avec ottawa et le nombre
d'immigrants temporaires ce qu'on
appelle les travailleurs étrangers
temporaires saut il y aura
vraisemblablement une augmentation audit
pour les admissions au delà de combien
une augmentation accrue aux biens ben on
était pour lille pour les travailleurs
étrangers temporaires à peu près à 30
milles en 2021 est donc sauf cette année
je pas en mesure d'anticiper combien il
va y en avoir mais plus qu'un entre
mille plus de 30000
probablement parce que avec le
traitement simplifié puis l'ajout d'un
certain nombre d'emplois métiers qui
vont bénéficier d'une voie rapide vers
les migrations temporaires il y en aura
certainement plus pour répondre aux
besoins des entreprises québécoises
monsieur le ministre merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci gérard au
plaisir à bientôt pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit